mira si no lo expulsan esto que él hace
le crea más fuerza física y mental en
lucha pero estas cosas las hacían
propósito que se crece ante el castigo a
ello sirve el público que se metan con
él y por lo tanto esto va a ser un poco
vaya lo mismo
le van a silbar cuando salga los
jugadores no le van a poner buena cara
en las salas de jugadores en los
comedores ni sé si van a querer aceptar
estar cerca de él pero a él esto no le
importa yo creo que esto lo tiene
absolutamente
superado no se una familia que el padre
dice que dios que la madre ahora con la
virgen que él es capaz de convertir el
agua sucia en agua limpia con cosas tan
extrañas tan difíciles de aceptar al que
creo que están haciendo un paripé que
están haciendo algo que no es lo que
piensan
ya lo hace para crecerse para ser más
fuerte para estar luchando contra todo
en el fondo no consigue eso número 2 del
mundo a nadie le va a negar sus virtudes
y tenísticas está claro que como tenista
es un auténtico fenómeno lo que pasa es
que creo que en los dos aspectos deja
bastante que desear